Mark Zuckerberg says his dream is for 1
billion people to spend real money in
his metaverse on fake digital Goods
despite average gas prices in the real
world at five dollars so Mark Zuckerberg
thinks that you know despite what's
going on in the world right now you know
you can't even fill up your gas tank to
get from point A to point B but you're
going to just take that cash the little
bit that you have saved on the side or
maybe you're living paycheck to paycheck
but you just take some and you're like
I'm gonna go I'm gonna have some fun in
the metaverse
I mean is this just does he just sit
with a bunch of rich people and I mean
no real person out there that's trying
to make ends meet or trying to I mean
nobody's thinking about the metaverse
mark nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
metaverse I don't they don't care you
know who cares about the metaverse
people who can afford to care to not
till to like to like they have so much
money that they're like well I spent all
my money in in the regular world and
I've done it all so let me just check
out the metaverse that's not your
average person
okay
what a nice idea too if you think about
it
Mark makes a pile of cash
people live inside their screens all the
time
they don't enter the real world
we all turn into a bunch of little
malleable puppets you ever see the
Muppet Show yeah that's what he wants
you to be
and then we all can become a bunch of
vegetables that could be spoon fed all
the propaganda that Mark puts on
Facebook you know how Facebook bans
certain things and then it's just like
you see like an endless stream during
the vaccine debate it was just like get
that get that I just like you couldn't
even open it it was just like vomiting
big Pharma talking points then somebody
goes on there and says something
different you trying to talk to me Tyler
well I I heard somewhere on a podcast
that former Pfizer Marketing Executives
now work at Facebook you know what you
heard that from very smart individual
who does deep dives into the topics that
people really care about really does
their research that's right
I can't take a bow because I'm already
seated but if I could I would plus I'd
be out of frame and that would be bad
Jorge would just be like sit down Jed we
didn't account for that don't be
spontaneous
so listen uh this is a hard pass for me
we talked about the metaverse we talked
about how they want you to be a puppet
we talked about how you need to learn
how to exist in the real world and in
real life and not be spending your money
in some metaverse and you already know
exactly you know that Facebook you know
that Silicon Valley wants you programmed
you know they study we talked about this
too they study Behavioral Science they
want you to be a little puppet so don't
give it to them you know what you say to
Mark hey Mark you know what it's a
beautiful day outside why don't you get
outside it seems like you might need to
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]